bonsoir et bienvenue ravi de vous
retrouver au menu de Ça vous regarde ce
soir regard sur l'Iran avec notre grand
témoin ce soir s'épider farci bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous êtes réalisatrice
iranienne la sirène votre premier film
d'animation est en salle depuis mercredi
dernier il raconte un moment de bascule
pour tous les Iraniens la guériront Irak
des années 80 qui fait forcément écho
avec les conflits et les soulèvements
d'aujourd'hui on en parle longuement
toutes les deux dans la deuxième partie
mais on commence évidemment ce soir par
la fièvre dans les banlieues qui ne
retombent pas deuxième nuit des modes
urbaines un peu partout en France le
spectre de 2005 et dans toutes les têtes
et pour Emmanuel Macron certains je cite
utilisent la mort de Naël pour créer le
désordre alors comment les stopper ces
violences et que fait-on en dehors des
crises la politique de la ville est-elle
un échec grand débat avec mes invités
dans un instant sur ce plateau avant de
retrouver 20h15 les affranchis leur
parti pris et puis
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée voilà pour le menu ce soir
on y va s'épider farci ça vous regarde
c'est parti
[Musique]
depuis 24 heures la donne a changé le
bilan des émeutes de la nuit dernière
est très lourd l'état d'urgence n'est
pas décrété mais le gouvernement se
réserve cette option très sérieusement
et sur le terrain personne n'est
véritablement surpris par ce
déchaînement de violence alors faut-il
attendre les crises dans les banlieues
pour agir hasard du calendrier un comité
un terminal de la ville s'est tenu en
pleine tempête à Matignon à la
mi-journée et la plupart de mes invités
ce soir était présent à ce comité dont
vous Nadia hey bonsoir bonsoir merci
d'être là vous êtes député renaissance
des Yvelines ou plusieurs villes
notamment trap dans votre
circonscription était frappée de plein
fouet l'ancienne circonscription ah oui
vous avez changé
d'autres villes dans les Yvelines et on
en parlera frappé de plein fouet vous
êtes ancienne ministre délégué et chargé
de la ville vous étiez aussi à ce comité
à Matignon Catherine Arnault bonsoir
merci d'être là mère divers droites de
Chanteloup-les-Vignes donc dans les
Yvelines ville également très touchées
on va en parler vous présidez
l'association des élus de ville et ban
bonsoir Saïda mouche merci d'être là
présent à Matignon aussi c'est
intéressant parce que vous allez nous
dire ce qui s'est dit vous êtes
fondateur de mosaïque RH et il faut
expliquer que c'est un très gros travail
que cette association fait dans les
banlieues pour l'emploi des jeunes on
fera un peu le bilan enfin bonsoir
Anthony cahier merci d'être là vous êtes
policier secrétaire général CGT police
qui se passe dans le pays nous
interpelle tous donc n'hésitez pas à
interroger nos invités on va commencer
par le dérouler des faits avec Stéphane
blackowski comme chaque soir la nuit
dernière et les réponses de l'exécutif
le chrono de Blacko pour commencer
et je me retourne je vous invite à faire
la même chose et puis des farcis pour
vous accueillir bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
à toutes et tous alors
nuit d'émeute consécutive en France donc
la première ministre à nouveau réunit
une cellule de crise interministériale
ce matin à Matignon en qualifiant bien
sûr les événements d'insupportable d'une
excusable avec l'occasion de faire un
premier bilan sur les événements de la
nuit donc vous voyez que les chips sont
assez impressionnants 875
interpellations dans toute la France à
peu près la moitié en
Île-de-France donc c'est cinq fois plus
que la nuit précédente mais malgré la
force présence policière 40 000
gendarmes et policiers sur le terrain il
y a eu 250 blessés surtout voyez presque
500 bâtiments incendiés 2000 véhicules
brûlés
qui étaient très nombreux cette nuit
donc ce qu'on peut constater les forces
de l'ordre sur les premiers retours
c'est que notamment par rapport au
profil des interpellés il y avait
beaucoup de gens très jeunes un tiers à
peu près d'entre eux étaient des mineurs
d'où l'appel ce matin par Olivier Klein
le ministre du Logement on écoute j'en
appelle à la responsabilité à la
responsabilité des parents notamment
pour que le soir ces jeunes soient chez
eux parce que ils se mettent eux-mêmes
en danger alors Olivier Klein vous le
savez sans doute c'est le Ministre du
Logement c'est aussi l'ancien maire de
Clichy-sous-Bois où ont lieu des émeutes
en 2005 et en vertu de cette expérience
ce qui disait ce matin c'est que si on
veut aller vers le retour au calme la
meilleure méthode c'est parler discuter
rétablir le dialogue et donc pour lui ça
serait une erreur de recourir en tout
cas maintenant à l'état d'urgence on
écoute pourquoi c'est pas le bon moyen
d'y revenir au calme un état d'urgence
mais parce que parce que c'est d'abord
un aveu d'échec enfin c'est mon
sentiment alors ça c'est l'aile gauche
de la majorité mais il y a aussi une
aile droite de la majorité qui n'est pas
forcément convaincu que la parole le
dialogue soit le meilleur manière pour
rétablir le canne je pense notamment à
Arnaud Robinet qui lui est mère de Reims
donc horizons le parti de Édouard
Philippe vous voyez qu'on paye des mots
très ce matin sur Twitter en parlant
donc de racailles et de hors de sauvages
qui étaient hier soir à Reims pour
piller détruire
brûler ce qu'il pouvait donc face à
cette situation la question plane sur
toute la journée c'est faut-il
déclencher l'état d'urgence vous savez
que c'est ce que réclamait Zemmour et
cieux qui hier le RN c'est réalisé cette
position ce matin mais c'était aussi
l'occasion pour Sébastien Chenu de se
faire le porte-parole d'une autre colère
que celle des amitiés la colère des
Français qui sont témoins de ces
violences et de ses incendies la
télévision on écoute quel rapport avec
la mort du jeune homme quel rapport avec
la mort de ce gamin de 17 ans la mort
dramatique de ce gamin de 17 ans que de
brûler le bus des femmes la piscine des
jeux olympiques les mairies les
médiathèques et les théâtres dans notre
pays aucun rapport ce sont des prétextes
car ces voyous détestent l'autorité et
des tests la France donc ça ne vous
surprendra évidemment pas si je vous dis
que du côté des insoumis à l'autre bout
de l'échiquier on pense exactement dans
le contraire martyle de panneaux c'est
d'exprimer ses dernières 24 heures d'une
part elle condamne pas elle les aimeiers
mais plutôt la répression du
gouvernement contre les émeutiers puis
que faut-il faire les insoumis eux
souhaitent modifier la loi pour
limiter le recours aux armes dans les
cas de refus d'obtempérer ça ce sont les
réactions politiques le président Macron
était à Bruxelles ce matin il est revenu
plus vite que prévu pour une nouvelle
réunion de crise alors qu'est-ce qu'il
faut retenir de ce qu'il a dit surtout
ce qu'il a pas dit il n'a pas appelé à
l'état d'urgence puisque c'était la
question qu'on se posait ensuite il a
rappelé ce que disait oliviers Klein
l'appel à la responsabilité des parents
ne laissez pas aux enfants sortir ce
soir une pression sur les réseaux
sociaux il a cité énormément snapchat et
Tik Tok qui servent souvent pour à la
fois s'organiser et appeler à la
violence ça c'est par rapport à la
situation et puis à propos plus
politique quand même où il a dénoncé la
récupération politique autour de ces
événements on l'écoute
il y a une instrumentalisation une
acceptable
de la mort d'un adolescent que nous
déplorons tous alors que la période
devrait être recueillement et au respect
et donc face à cela je condamne avec la
plus grande fermeté toutes celles et
ceux qui utilisent
cette situation et ce moment pour
essayer de créer le désordre et
d'attaquer nos institutions toutes
celles et ceux donc comme personne n'est
cité nommément vous allez voir imaginer
chacun qui est visé par ses propos du
président en attendant ce qui est sûr
c'est que si à l'issue du week-end et
bien le calme n'est pas revenu on va
reparler l'état d'urgence forcément
merci beaucoup Stéphane on va commencer
par voilà vous remonter de terrain
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans les Yvelines
en particulier et comment vous Nadia
vous comprenez ce soulèvement de colère
cette mort nous fout la haine ça c'est
ce que disait un jeune hier qui
participait à Nanterre à la marche
blanche est-ce que vous retrouvez les
ingrédients les éléments de 2005 alors
d'abord ce qui se passe dans les
Yvelines c'est un peu ce qui se passe
partout sur le territoire national à la
différence près c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
y a certaines
communes qui sont touchées alors
qu'elles n'avaient jamais été touchées
jusque là par les différents événements
sociaux sociétaux qu'on a connu dans nos
quartiers et donc ça c'est vraiment la
nouveauté une autre côté c'est que c'est
des bandes organisées
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui il
s'organise de manière beaucoup plus
ils sont beaucoup plus structurés ça va
très très vite donc c'est que il y a une
préparation ce ne sont pas des des
mouvements spontanés c'est qui ce qu'on
allait faire vous avez soit des jeunes
des quartiers expérimentés avec
différents
actes de violence dont ils sont les
spécialistes et puis vous avez d'autres
personnes qui ne sont pas connues de des
élus et qui viennent dans le territoire
commettre ces actes de violence brûlés
ou même pillés donc
c'est quoi et je pense que justement et
c'est ce que dit le président de la
République sur la question des
phénomènes des des réseaux sociaux qui
permettent une structuration des
mouvements des actes et une organisation
bien en amont de la soirée
n'est qu'un prétexte la mort de Naël
c'est une collective dont vous parlez
organisée qui viennent de l'extérieur
des villes c'est une étincelle et
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est un
prétexte pour exprimer pour beaucoup une
certaine colère et c'est vrai que ce que
ce à quoi nous assistons aujourd'hui qui
sont des violences encore une fois
inacceptables que l'on doit condamner
tous de manière très forte et sur lequel
nous devons avoir une action collective
et c'est bien ce qui a rappelé le
président de la République c'est-à-dire
que évidemment l'État est présent et
répond présent à ses obligations et sa
responsabilité mais également le courage
des élus locaux qui sont sur place et
qui là aussi mettent tous les tous les
toutes les dispositions prévues par la
municipalité pour sur les la police
municipale les caméras de vidéos
protection les élus qui sont sur le
terrain qui ne ferment pas l'oeil de la
nuit et qui sont qui sont là et puis
vous avez tout le le
l'écosystème si je puis dire donc les
médiateur les éducateurs le tissu
d'association de proximité qui est aussi
là en amont première ligne pour essayer
de calmer ces jeunes mais il en résultat
pour lequel il faut absolument sur
lesquels il faut absolument sucer c'est
la responsabilité des parents
aujourd'hui et ça a été dit cette nuit
beaucoup de mineurs beaucoup trop de
mineurs étaient 12 ans en première les
interpellés donc je dis aux parents si
votre enfant n'est pas à la maison à 21h
à 22h
quand il est adolescent c'est soit il
est en train de commettre des actes de
violence soit il est en danger donc de
toutes les manières il n'a rien à faire
dehors en pleine nuit dans le contexte
actuel Catherine Arnaud votre analyse de
la situation chante nous leving est
évidemment percuté par ces violences
qu'est-ce que vous comprenez est-ce que
vous êtes surprise déjà par
l'embrasement ou pas du tout parce que
le feu Couvet d'une certaine façon déjà
dans les relations peut-être avec la
police
je suis désespérée parce que je ne suis
pas surprise et parce que c'était un
propos sans vouloir crier ou loutre le
temps c'était à propos que nous avions
nous mère de banlieue mais toutes les
associations des livres vous savez
depuis plusieurs mois travaillé ensemble
et elles avaient ce sentiment que les
choses que la désespérance s'aggravait
et que cette désespérance peut toujours
engendrer engendrer des mouvements
et voilà comment je peux le comprendre
moi la désespérance s'aggravait nous
avons vécu bien évidemment la France
entière a vécu le covid la crise
énergétique mais dans les quartiers les
quartiers en fait ça n'est pas une
géographie les quartiers c'est le lieu
où un certain nombre d'habitants et
généralement en grande densité tous
relativement précaires vivent ensemble
donc c'est c'est en fait la densité des
habitants qui ont le plus de difficultés
sur nos territoires qui sont rassemblés
c'est ça ce qu'on appelle les quartiers
faut pas voir ça comme une géographie
faut voir ça comme comme un lieu où sont
des habitants donc il faut les regarder
chacun individuellement pour essayer de
comprendre quand vous avez dans une
famille des adultes qui sont en
difficulté parce qu'ils ont perdu leur
emploi l'emploi qu'ils ont retrouvé très
précaires les charges ils ont vécu le
covid ça les a quand même beaucoup
marqués parce qu'ils ont été très
enfermés les charges énergétiques
sont-elles certes la France les vies
mais en proportion des revenus c'est
bien plus important quand le quand vous
avez brusquement 300 euros de plus de
charges par mois c'est bien plus
important sur des vous condamnez ces
violences
quand vous vivez ça quand la famille vit
ça l'adolescent il entend ça et il
entend cette désespérance au quotidien
bien évidemment les adultes ne sont pas
revendicateurs ils vivent leur
désespérance et il l'a et il la décrète
ils entendent bien les parents qui vont
l'accès aux droits ils entendent bien
voilà donc à un moment donné c'est sûr
qu'il y a une rupture et l'adolescent
par nature tous les adolescents ne
vivent qu'en excès et quand quand
réaction alors là où il y a là où le
babelet effectivement là je suis assez
d'accord c'est quand même un moment
donné il faut qu'on reste parents tout
ça même dans la désespérance faut qu'on
reste parents c'est aussi la politique
de la vie c'est comment on accompagne
ses parisiens qui sont assez qui sont un
peu en difficulté à rester parents même
d'un adolescent qui commence à lâcher
qui commence à lâcher prise ce soir pour
le moment mes responsabilités des
parents on l'a dit les réseaux sociaux
aussi c'est suffisant pour vous moi je
ne crois que la solution locale
cohérente solution locale parce qu'elles
sont toutes adaptées au terrain c'est
parce que les éducateurs sont présents
ils connaissent les jeunes et puis on
connaît pas les jeunes du coup on ne
connaît pas le groupe de jeunes mais on
connaît un ou deux jeunes dont on
imagine qu'il fait partie du groupe et
c'est comme ça en allant chercher parce
que le raisonnable quand on a 15 ans
déjà on l'entend pas mais quand on la
case dans cette ambiance des meute c'est
encore moins accessible mais c'est c'est
l'éducateur c'est le médiateur c'est
c'est l'éducateur
sportifs comme ça sur le terrain mais
c'est du micro mais là c'est mais nous
faisons de la dentelle et c'est cette
dentelle là quelquefois qui marche en
tout cas dans ces moments aussi
dramatiques comment vous comprenez ce
qui se joue on entend parler de
collectif organisés est-ce que vous
savez qui sont ces gens certaines vidéos
incriminent les islamistes est-ce que
c'est le cas des jeunes aussi très très
jeunes tout ça est-il nouveau alors
c'est pas nouveau parce que en fait
c'est une situation en fait qui était
attendue malheureusement je vous entends
encore à plusieurs reprises dans des
réunions stratégiques l'évoquées donc ça
couvait on le savait et c'est aussi la
conséquence en fait de différentes
ruptures qui ont eu lieu depuis un
certain nombre d'années c'est-à-dire que
à partir du moment où les établissements
sportifs sont moins dotés et bien
derrière on a moins d'encadrant à partir
du moment où les profs ont moins de
moyens et sont moins respectés dans leur
boulot ça aussi des conséquences parce
que c'était aussi un filtre à partir du
moment où les associations sont moins
financées et bien à un moment donné le
bélota a une limite et il y a plus de
filtres en réalité il y a le plus de
filets de sécurité donc l'éducation
populaire qui a été pendant des années
un filet protecteur et qui a permis en
fait de faire le tampon d'expliquer
d'accompagner les uns et les autres n'ex
peut plus vraiment on est plus dans les
mêmes dynamiques et donc il faut se
réinventer et donc se réinventer ça
passe par investir dans de nouvelles
solutions dans des nouvelles
trajectoires des nouveaux récits des
nouvelles dynamiques et c'est ça qui est
attendu aujourd'hui je crois on va
parler des solutions de ce que vous êtes
dit la première ministre qui jette de
lui sur le feu pour vous aujourd'hui
parce que le Président il a été à la
fois clair et un peu ambigu parle
d'instrumentalisation il parle aussi
d'utilisation de cette mort pour créer
du désordre il pointe qui des casseurs
il pointe les politiques
moi je pense que on est dans une
situation où tout le monde s'interroge
cherche des solutions essaie de
s'appliquer moi je pense que tout le
monde est de bonne volonté en réalité et
les policiers faut leur rendre hommage
c'est quand même ce que je cherche les
habitants de ces quartiers c'est d'être
aussi en sécurité c'est aussi de jouir
en fait des services des gardiens de la
paix donc on est sur cette base là donc
à mon avis cette petite musique autour
de celui qui jette de l'huile de feu
c'est pas c'est pas le débat le débat il
doit être autour de qu'est-ce qu'on fait
demain c'est ce qu'attendent aujourd'hui
les citoyens ils ont un sentiment de
mépris ils ont un sentiment d'être
inconsidéré comment on s'organise pour
pouvoir avancer là-dessus alors le lien
dans les banlieues avec la population et
la police Anthony cailler en regardant
les différents portages en écoutant les
uns les autres on se rend compte que
c'est très difficile et de et depuis
longtemps même pour organiser des
rencontres populations police dans
certaines villes on ne trouve plus de
participants il y a eu pas mal de
témoignages je vous confirmez cela ou
pas
oui nous on le confirme et ça fait des
années qu'on le dit il y a une rupture
totale qui a été engagée par le
politique à la direction successive de
gouvernement depuis au moins 2005 il y a
vraiment eu un point de bascule à
l'arrivée de Nicolas Sarkozy ou on a une
rupture totale entre la police et ses
citoyens ça c'est total je pense que
aujourd'hui
à la police nationale
d'appliquer uniquement des missions de
répression et vous ne pouvez plus du
tout être dans une dynamique de
discussion
d'entente d'écoute sur le terrain
pédestrement qui plus est dans les
quartiers oui il y a une rupture totale
et puis la police du quotidien qui
revenait même si c'était pas la police
de proximité tout ça c'est
efficace c'est pas que c'est inefficace
c'est que je pense ça n'a jamais existé
en fait et des effets d'annonce on nous
a promis effectivement deux trois fois
par deux trois logos différents de
remettre de la proximité sur le terrain
mais de toute façon matériellement ce
n'est plus possible vu le nombre de
policiers qu'il reste dans les
commissariats on est plus en capacité
d'opérer ce type de mission on est à
peine en capacité aujourd'hui
ce qui est dit n'est pas vrai
aujourd'hui il y a en 2022 plus 30% de
démission on ne parle pas des départs à
la retraite on parle bien de démission
ça le l'embauche qui est fait par le
ministère de l'Intérieur aujourd'hui ne
couvre même pas ses démissions donc on
est à peu près à 110 000 111.000
policiers statutaires je vous garantis
que dans deux ans dans trois ans
l'hémorragie va continuer on sera encore
on va dire plus globalement de ce qu'on
pourrait faire de la politique de la
ville mais il y a une espèce
maintenant est-ce que en tant que
policier en tant qu'élu vous réclamez on
va dire un maintien de l'ordre plus
offensif le président a dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de tabou pas d'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence ça permet il faut le
dire rappeler les gens s'en souviennent
mais c'est les assignations à résidence
les perquisitions administratives les
couvre-feu est-ce que ça c'est pas utile
tout de suite pour empêcher
l'embrasement tirons les leçons de 2005
est-ce que l'état d'urgence qui a été
mise en place en 2005 a servi à quelque
chose non non moi je vous le dis j'étais
en Seine-Saint-Denis en 2005 ça n'a
servi à rien qui plus est à quoi servira
l'état d'urgence aujourd'hui je vous
rappelle que depuis 2001 qui est un peu
plus d'une vingtaine de lois de sécurité
qui ont été mises en place notamment la
loi sécurité globale qui a repris à son
compte une grande partie de l'état
d'urgence donc en fait on est
potentiellement tous les jours en état
d'urgence aujourd'hui et cette loi
sécurité des globale qu'est-ce qu'on en
attendait on en attendait effectivement
on a dit on met plus de répression plus
de surveillance dans les quartiers et
dans les villes le caméra vidéo sur plus
d'agents de sécurité privée plus de
police pour surveiller tout le monde et
finalement on se retrouve dans la même
situation qu'en 2005 mais je tiens quand
même à préciser je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que vous dites ce n'est
pas vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est Pierre
qu'en 2005 comparaison n'est pas par
exemple déjà c'est très compliqué
aujourd'hui de faire la comparaison 2005
ça a duré plus de 3 semaines sur un peu
plus de 90 départements en France sur
100 ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on est très loin de ces 90
départements touchés par les émotes
urbaines les différences elles sont
elles sont notables Nadia alors d'abord
pour répondre aussi à votre question
c'est l'heure aujourd'hui elle est à
l'ordre républicain il faut ramener de
l'apaisement il faut ramener du calme il
faut cesser ses actes de violence donc
ça va parler démonstration fort de
l'exécutif peut-être même de la police
oui mais il va y avoir justement des
moyens supplémentaires encore qui vont
être déployés sur le terrain ce soir
donc il faut rétablir l'ordre dans les
meilleurs délais pour pouvoir traiter
qu'il faut aller plus loin dans le
maintien parce que tout le monde craint
la bavure supplémentaire justement je ne
suis peut-être des ministres de
l'Intérieur et encore moins les
professionnels qui sont sur le terrain
pour savoir exactement ce qu'il faut
faire mais je pense que déjà d'une part
des forces supplémentaires c'est
important pour venir épauler c'est les
forces qui sont sur le terrain et je
peux vous dire pour avoir discuté avec
les le directeur de la sécurité publique
du département différents commissaires
le préfet également du département tout
le monde est mobilisé toute la nuit donc
il faut venir appuyer ces équipes qui
sont là et qui qui
œuvrent d'arrache-pied pour amener le
calme maintenant juste revenir sur ce
qu'a dit Monsieur à l'instant qui je
pense aussi le Léman déclencheur de
cette révolte de ses émeutes de ce qu'on
de ces actes de violence des jeunes des
quartiers c'est le lien entre la police
et les jeunes de nos quartiers c'est
l'élément déclencheur de cette révolte
et par des ruptures totales il y a une
rupture effectivement parce que la
police et les jeunes
dans un même territoire il se côtoie
tous les jours mais ils sont pleins de
préjugés d'un côté comme de l'autre des
on jette l'eau propre sur nos forces de
pôles depuis quand de l'autre côté
ça fait des années et ça fait des années
et vous voyez moi il y a rien de pire
pour pour la jeune des quartiers que
j'étais l'élu encore aujourd'hui de nos
quartiers que de voir des pancartes on
affiche la police tue alors qu'on s'est
pertinemment que c'est la première force
protectrice dans du slogan et donc
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et donc là
aujourd'hui ce qu'il faut qu'on arrive à
faire c'est rétablir ce lien entre les
jeunes entre nos avec nos forces de
police parce qu'il ne faut jeter ni le
discrédit sur la police même si
effectivement il y a des actes violents
de policiers il y a du racisme par
certains policiers il y a de la
discrimination par certains policiers
mais ce n'est pas la généralité la
majorité de nos policiers comme de
l'autre côté il y a des trafiquants
minoritaires il y a des délinquants qui
sont minoritaires et ce n'est pas la
jeunesse dans nos quartiers qui est soit
trafiquant soit délinquant il y a
vraiment un travail réagir
la mort de Naël c'était un une mort de
trop il faut pas qu'il y ait des
dérapages comme ça moi je viens d'un
pays où je connais la violence dans la
rue j'ai je l'ai vraiment vécu et quand
on se retrouve en France à craindre
lorsqu'on va en manif de comment on va
revenir moi j'ai laissé ma fille on
était à Nanterre toutes les deux quand
on s'est séparés j'avais un rendez-vous
j'ai dû partir j'avais peur pour elle je
verse ça n'est pas normal ça n'est pas
normal lorsque Monsieur parle de la
rupture totale c'est vrai on l'a senti
moi je l'ai vu venir ça fait quasiment
40 ans que je vis en France les premiers
mai j'en ai fait jusqu'à un certain 1er
mai où ça a dérapé puis et puis voilà et
en quoi et ça c'est pas normal c'est pas
bien le métier de policier est un métier
très difficile et c'est vrai vous avez
raison vous aussi mais c'est pas en
déclarant des crétin l'état d'urgence
que on va calmer les choses c'était on
était en indice moi je me suis retrouvée
hier au côté d'un monsieur qui avait
perdu son fils il y a 16 mois sur une
moto parce que la moto avait été
percutée par un véhicule de policier je
vais il attend il attend voilà bon ça
fait c'est trop c'est trop c'est pas
possible allez on va avancer sur la
politique de la ville vous voulez
rajouter à quelque chose sur le l'état
des lieux dans l'urgence absolue j'ai
quand même le sentiment que au regard en
fait des difficultés de recrutement au
regard de ces c'est c'est cette rupture
qui a été mis en place il y a besoin
aujourd'hui probablement de faire ce
qu'on a fait dans les années 90
c'est-à-dire recruté dans les quartiers
si on recrutait davantage de policiers
issus en fait de ces quartiers
populaires je peux vous dire qu'on aura
une nouvelle génération aujourd'hui
et puis quand on recrute aujourd'hui pas
suffisamment et quand on recrute il faut
aussi penser à la mobilité c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut avoir des
candidats à des postes de commissaire de
police à des postes sur des
fonctionnaires et cette discrimination
elle existe aussi au sein de la police
et c'est aussi comme ça qu'on peut
relever la dynamique de l'espoir alors
il y avait donc ce comité
interministériel de la ville aujourd'hui
il a été maintenu mais manifestement il
était là pour plutôt entendre les élus
et leur remontées de terrain on va
essayer de dresser un bilan c'est
succins mais on va vous vous entendre
juste après c'est Maïté Frémont qui
essaye de nous dire ce qui est devenu la
fameuse promesse d'Emmanuel Macron dans
finir avec l'assignation à résidence
regardez
je veux que le visage de mon quartier
échanger à la fin de ce quinquennat il y
a eu cette phrase prononcée il y a 6 ans
et celle-ci prononçait en 2016 moi j'ai
un ennemi c'est l'assignation à
résidence les gens bloqués dans leur
situation cantonnée à leur quartier des
paroles qui permettent à Emmanuel Macron
d'être soutenu dans les quartiers et qui
ont suscité beaucoup d'espoir dès son
arrivée au pouvoir en 2017 Emmanuel
Macron met en place le dédoublement des
classes de CP et de CE1 dans les zones
d'éducation prioritaire avec une visée
fondamentale qui est la lutte contre les
inégalités la lutte pour la justice
sociale la lutte pour le progrès social
s'ensuit une mission confiée à l'ancien
ministre de la Ville Jean-Louis Borlo un
plan d'action pour la réconciliation
nationale qui sera finalement jeté aux
oubliettes avec cette phrase du
Président je vais pas vous faire un plan
parce que
quelque part ça n'aurait aucun sens
que
deux mâles blancs ne vivant pas dans ces
quartiers s'échangent l'un rapport et
l'autre disant on m'a remis un plan je
l'ai découvert c'est pas vrai ça marche
plus comme ça les gens qui vivent qui
font parfois depuis des décennies ce
sont des acteurs de ces sujets à partir
de là Emmanuel Macron laissera ses
premiers ministres lancés des opérations
de rattrapage d'abord Édouard Philippe
et son plan pour la Seine-Saint-Denis
avec notamment une prime de 10000 euros
pour les fonctionnaires qui resteront 5
ans en poste ces services font
face à Lionel dans le domaine des
ressources humaines qu'on retrouve très
rarement ailleurs Jean Castex prend le
relais en attribuant 1% du plan de
relance au banlieue aujourd'hui les
quartiers s'embrassent et cette question
en suspens dans le tourbillon des
réformes et des politiques publiques les
banlieues n'auraient-elles pas été
délaissée par Emmanuel Macron
délaisser le mot peut-être un peu fort
Catherine Arnoux vous qui sortez de
Matignon que vous a dit la première
ministre il s'agissait je crois de
discuter du plan quartier 2030
en tout cas c'est ce que j'en ai compris
au moins à la fin il s'agissait de
rassembler les associations d'élus et
les associations qui œuvrent sur les
territoires donc dans ce qu'on appelle
les quartiers pour pour les écouter les
écouter sur un temps qui n'était enfin
pas pour les écouter sur le fond mais
pour les écouter sur un temps qui était
attend d'urgence et un temps
d'inquiétude collectif voilà la réunion
a tourné essentiellement là-dessus elle
a été consacrée qu'à ça oui absolument
et moi je reviendrai je suis désolé
à plutôt raison ça n'est pas un problème
entre la police et la population et les
populations c'est nos populations sont
demandeuses de la police c'est un
problème de cette relation entre les
jeunes
et certains jeunes parce qu'ils sont là
et puis et puis la police dans ces
difficultés d'exercer ces fonctions
justement dans ces coins et puis dans un
ambiance où toute la société a changé
toute la société c'est aggravé les les
premiers mai ne se passe plus maintenant
comme il se passait il y a 20 ans et
bien non nos quartiers ne sont pas
exemples de cette évolution de la
société et donc c'est devenu très
difficile mais moi je sais cette nuit la
nuit d'avant et la nuit encore avant je
peux vous assurer qu'il y a des
quartiers qui réclamaient la police et
qu'ils n'ont pas eu le fait de le dire
merci alors les habitants les habitants
de la ville de famille ils l'attendent
aussi la boutique de la ville vous êtes
de ces élus qui parlaient haut et fort
et on vous a entendu au moment de du
travail avec Jean-Louis Borloo votre
déception aussi en 2018 parce que ce
rapport n'a pas été prise en compte
comment vous juger cette politique de la
ville on parle des cités éducatives du
dédoublement des classes en CPC en Rep
on parle aussi du collège ouvert
aujourd'hui depuis qu'Emmanuel Macron
est allé à Marseille de 8 heures à
quel bilan vous tirez tout toutes ces
décisions là on peut pas penser
politique de la ville en faisant une
succession de détails c'est pas possible
c'est pas une liste à la Prévert il faut
que ce enfin moi ce dont je suis sûr
c'est un moment donné s'il n'y a pas une
compréhension complète de ce que sont
les quartiers de nos territoires et une
volonté à la fois de respecter les
habitants et de prendre à bras le corps
cette politique qui n'est pas une
politique de charité il faut arrêter de
penser que c'est une politique
pratiquement les gens ne mériteraient
pas ça ça sera assez honteux l'idée
c'est quand même que tout doit être plus
dense en politique publique dans nos
quartiers à la fois dans le normal ce
qu'on appelle le droit commun et dans
l'exceptionnel pourquoi parce que nos
quartiers sont une densité de population
plus précaire plus importante qu'il y a
mais on va peut-être y réfléchir on va
peut-être aller jusqu'au bout de la
réflexion est-ce que vous croyez que les
gens qui vont pas bien ont plus envie
d'être de vivre tous ensemble en fait
c'est la nation entière c'est la France
entière qui depuis 40 ans a accepté que
ces zones de concentration
essentiellement dans le logement social
et maintenant pas que dans les dans des
zones de copropriété dégradées la France
entière a accepté qui est des
concentrations sur le calife faire de
temps en temps du cosmétique de la de la
voilà de la poudre simplement et sans
vouloir se dire à un moment donné on est
on doit tous porter la solidarité vous
êtes très sévère mais quand on regarde
vous dites que c'est pas des des
successions de mesure il y a eu des
milliards pour leur rue l'aménagement
urbain ça c'est c'est dans le bilan il y
a des choses qui ont été faites aussi
pour pour l'emploi dans les quartiers
est-ce que le chômage des des jeunes a
baissé non c'est pas le cas on constate
que le chômage des jeunes c'est pas moi
qui le revendique c'est le dernier
rapport de la Cour des comptes qui fait
état que malgré une politique assez
active et positive sur la jeunesse le
taux de on a voulu redynamiser le taux
d'emploi des jeunes en ayant mis en
place le dispositif un jeu une solution
ça a super bien marché on n'a jamais eu
un taux d'emploi aussi fort au niveau
des jeunes donc on a vraiment rompu avec
le chômage des jeunes en tout cas réduit
mais ça a eu aucune portée en fait sur
le chômage dans les quartiers politiques
de la ville ça c'est une réalité parce
que je pense que les dispositifs vont
pas assez loin je pense que lorsqu'on
crée en fait une dynamique de
financement à travers des emplois des
entreprises elles vont plutôt être dans
leur pratique classique c'est-à-dire
qu'on va plutôt recruter des gens qui
sont dans notre sphère directe que
d'aller chercher un peu plus loin là où
c'est plus complexe
par exemple les jeunes les jeunes
apprentis le process de discrimination
se retrouvent sur l'alternance sur le
stage et sur l'emploi
oui évidemment que la discrimination
existe dans nos quartiers et on est loin
d'avoir réglé le problème de la
discrimination mais bon sur les chiffres
du chômage dans les quartiers l'Insee
contredit le rapport de la Cour des
comptes donc faut qu'ils se mettent
d'accord sur les chiffres mais l'Insee
au contraire dit que le chômage des
jeunes après la crise et dans nos
quartiers à diminuer contrairement à la
crise de 2008 mais vous voyez Véronique
qui se mettent sortir de l'assignation à
résidence c'était la grande promesse
présidentielle aujourd'hui on parle
d'assignation à résidence avec l'urgence
c'est quand même terrible on a mis 40
ans pour construire ces quartiers et
pour construire les difficultés enfin
pour participer justement à ce que les
difficultés se superposent et à aucun
moment on a pris le sujet à bras le
corps en disant qu'il faut qu'il faut
mener une action dans le même temps
c'est un rapport avec une liste à la
Prévert et c'est ce qui a dénoncé à
l'instant madame Areno en disant ce
n'est pas avec une liste à la Prévert
que nous allons réussir et le comité
intermittéraire à la ville pardonnez-moi
de défendre aussi le bilan que j'ai
porté et que j'assume avec Jean Castex
nous avons mis en place un comité
interministériel à la ville auquel nous
avons convié les associations telles que
celles de mosaïque RH Saïda mouche mais
également les associations de
villemomieux donc on l'a construit
ensemble et c'est ce qu'avait essayé de
faire le Jean-Louis Borloo un rapport
moi même j'ai participé et donc on a
pris des idées du rapport Borlo mais
aussi on s'est inspiré de l'urgence du
moment et de la crise sanitaire que nous
étions en train de vivre et nous avons
construit ensemble un comité
interministériel à la ville avec une
liste de mesures oui mais avec une
méthode renouvelée une méthode de
co-construction et on a inversé
totalement le paradigme c'est-à-dire des
décisions qui auraient été décidées
depuis Paris et qui devrait s'appliquer
comme ça à mettre en oeuvre directement
par les accords de avec les acteurs de
terrain donc on a inversé ce paradigme
là est-ce que Emmanuel Macron est en
train de relever le pari qu'il nous
avait lancé en 2000 en 2017 très
objectivement la réponse est oui parce
que nos quartiers se transforment moi
quand je vais voir quand je vais chez
catherine-narino à Chanteloup-les-Vignes
je suis en train de voir une cité
éducative qui est en train de naître de
la par le bâti qui est en train d'être
construite dans le dieu problème aussi
c'est la sociologie quand ça va mieux
pour vous dans les quartiers ben vous
déménagez c'est aussi ça a une
difficulté sincèrement parce qu'il faut
savoir que certaines personnes qui sont
restées dans les quartiers vous savez
déloger ma mère de la tour du septième
étage dans laquelle j'ai grandi je suis
née j'ai grandi allait la déloger de là
et bien elle ne veut pas partir parce
que c'est chez elle et elle veut que ça
se transforme
en discutant avec les acteurs sur le
terrain avec les forces de police avec
les acteurs économiques avec les acteurs
associatifs on a réussi à changer à
amener de la sérénité dans des villes
comme allez comme une dernière question
et comme d'autres communes on va venir
Toulouse c'est en train de se
transformer juste pour terminer donc il
ne faut pas je pense faire le lien avec
la politique de la ville qui est en
train de qui a toujours d'ailleurs
fourni du résultat et là qui est en
train de monter en puissance avec un
changement total de paradigme avec ce
que nous sommes en train de vivre
aujourd'hui qui est un mal-être de nos
jeunes qui est un cri d'alerte qui sont
en train de nous lancer sur le fait
qu'ils ont été traités en mars notre
société qui ne font pas partie de la
communauté de calendrier c'est pour ça
qu'on s'intéresse aussi à la politique
de la ville aujourd'hui donc dernière
question
de ce matin c'était effectivement faire
le point de ce qui de l'état
actuel et de l'urgence dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons pour amener le calme
et les mesures arriveront après dernière
petite question rapide réponse sur sur
la sécurité sur l'IGPN est-ce que vous
pensez que la France un jour se dotera
d'un organisme indépendant de la police
pour juger les policiers vous le
souhaitez à la CGT je rappelle que vous
êtes ultra minoritaire au sein de la
police pour les juger je ne sais pas si
c'est souhaitable en tout cas pour
amener une expertise une enquête oui
c'est très souhaitable notamment en
termes ne serait-ce que d'image de que
nos citoyens réconcilier exactement bon
voilà on s'arrête là c'est le c'est le
début j'espère que voilà on n'aura pas à
se revoir pendant toute la semaine
prochaine bon courage aux élus locaux et
merci d'être venu sur LCP vous restez
avec moi s'épilé farci dans une dizaine
de minutes les parties pris de nos
affranchis ce soir obtempérer c'est le
mode de la semaine forcément
de Mariette darrigranle jeune philosophe
Nathan devais se pencher sur l'autre
Trump de la campagne américaine pour la
Maison Blanche et puis d'un Bourbon
Express ce soir de quoi nous parlez-vous
Marco pommier une France à 50 degrés
c'est le scénario cauchemardesque auquel
les écologistes veulent nous préparer je
vous raconte tout à l'heure merci à vous
à tout à l'heure les amis d'abord on va
plonger dans la sirène c'est un bateau
dans ce film d'animation le premier que
vous signez cette idée farci il est en
salle depuis deux jours c'est votre
vision d'une guerre oubliée la guerre
des années 80 Iran Irak l'une des plus
meurtrières de la deuxième moitié du 20e
siècle c'est un moment de bascule pour
tous les Iraniens on va y revenir et
c'est un moment qui fait forcément écho
à ce que traverse aujourd'hui toute la
société iranienne mais aussi d'autres
conflits dans le monde regardait c'est
dans l'invitation signé Pierre Michael
Carniel on en parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite c'est vidé par ci et
c'est parce que vous avez réalisé la
sirène un film d'animation sur l'Iran
des années 80 sorti en salle mercredi
c'est un peu un film autobiographique
vous racontez votre jeunesse à travers
l'histoire d'omid un adolescent qui voit
sa vie basculer lors du siège d'abadans
un des épisodes les plus marquants de la
guerre entre l'Iran et l'Irak à l'époque
dans cet extrait vous jouez avec le
voile et sa symbolique
[Musique]
vous commencez à réaliser ce film en
2019 bien avant la révolte iranine
actuelle déclenchée par la mort de Macha
Amini arrêté tué par la police du régime
en 2022 parce qu'elle refusait de porter
le voile
mais à Téhéran 1965 sébidé farci vous
fuyez le régime démolas pour Paris en
1984 vous y étudier les mathématiques
mais à l'aube de vos vingt ans votre
amour pour les arts visuels vous
poussent à devenir réalisatrice
depuis vous n'avez cessé de brosser le
portrait de l'Iran vous vous faites
remarquer en 2009 avec Téhéran sans
autorisation un documentaire filmé
intégralement au téléphone portable
puis en 2014 vous réalisez red rose une
histoire d'amour dans la République
islamique
[Musique]
des films qui déplaisent au régime et
qui vous ont valu d'être interdit de ces
jours en Iran aujourd'hui votre eSport
et que la sirène soit vu clandestinement
dans votre pays d'origine en janvier
vous avez signé une tribune dans Le
Monde en appelant l'Occident à ne plus
s'adresser aux mots là du régime iranien
alors nous avons une question pour vous
ces bidets farcie pensez-vous
sincèrement que la chute du régime est
pour bientôt
la répression extrêmement violente des
mots là les exécutions les pendaisons la
torture les prisons remplis de jeunes la
résistance continue malgré ça c'est ça
le courage de des femmes des hommes des
jeunes qui
qui continue à résister qui brave
l'interdit malgré le risque d'aller en
prison malgré le risque de perdre leur
travail de tout ce qui voilà cette idée
reliant par exemple une activité elle a
été libérée il y a quelques mois après
presque 5 ans de prison à peine sur ce
devant la prison elle a dit à Baroni
elle a été arrêté le jour même c'est
c'est ce genre d'acte qui nous donne
l'espoir et qui montre que on va y
arriver c'est la jeunesse qui détient la
clé de du changement en errant c'est
cette jeunesse à laquelle vous consacrez
votre film c'était important de la
montrer aussi oui alors c'est pas la
même génération aujourd'hui les jeunes
qui sont dans la rue sont les enfants
des enfants qui ont grandi sous la
Révolution enfin après la Révolution
sous la République islamique ça montre
bien que justement les produits de ce
régime pur produit enfin de système
éducatif et sociétal aujourd'hui c'est
cela qui se révolte et moi ce je monte
c'est la génération la mienne en fait
moi j'avais quasiment l'âge de homid
quand la guerre a éclaté alors quel
jeune fille étiez vous dans ces années
là parce que c'est un peu votre histoire
malgré tout que vous racontez c'est
aussi onirique et ça fait beaucoup de
passerelles vous avez quitté l'Iran vous
étiez étudiante à peine non non j'avais
mon en fait j'ai fait de la prison à 16
ans et sortie de prison en 82 je n'avais
plus le droit de d'étudier donc du coup
j'ai dû pour vivre en fait quitter
l'Iran pour pouvoir continuer à faire
mes études commencer mes études en fait
et après évidemment pour suivre avec le
cinéma qui était mon amour je savais
déjà que je voulais faire des films la
sirène donc c'est l'histoire d'omid un
jeune adolescent qui veut sauver sa
famille qui veut sauver son village
assiégé par les par les Irakiens une
ville martyre grâce à un bateau
c'est une sorte d'arche qui va lui
permettre de s'engager mais sans prendre
les armes
exactement ce qui était important pour
moi c'était de montrer comment on peut
résister en fait cette pour un
adolescent qui n'est plus un enfant mais
qui n'est pas encore un adulte trouver
la façon de résister la plus juste sans
avoir recours à la violence justement la
violence dont on parlait à l'instant et
donc l'Iran et l'Irak ont beaucoup
souffert effectivement de ce conflit
donc montrer autre chose et puis avoir
recours à la à la poésie aussi pour
montrer autre chose alors l'animation
pourquoi l'animation alors on imagine
que c'était impossible pour vous d'aller
tourner dans ce village que vous
décrivez ce village martyr c'est une
grande ville en fait un village une
grande ville
il fallait passer par par le dessin
animé comment il est né ce projet pour
plusieurs raisons en fait j'avais dès le
départ envie de le de traiter ce sujet
en animation
ah c'était pour avoir la distance
nécessaire avec les faits
de ce conflit et quand même le conflit
le deuxième conflit majeur de la
deuxième moitié du 20e siècle après la
guerre du Vietnam
et le cinéma que je fais en fait c'est
un cinéma différent n'est pas un cinéma
de studio de grands effets voilà de
guerre et du coup l'animation était le
médium juste en plus ça donnait la
distance parce que c'est quand même une
ode à la vie aussi c'est à la résistance
c'est pas un film de guerre que je fais
c'est un ensemble ce côté poétique était
aussi important que la partie historique
et l'animation permettait de combiner ça
regardez cette bague
c'est une bague qui vient de l'Algérie
c'est une bague kabyle que ma mon oncle
qui était exilé en France à offert à ma
tante tous les deux sont morts ici à
Paris décédé en exil sans pouvoir
retourner en Iran ça c'est un peu la
bague qu'on voit dans le film qui ouvre
le début du film justement c'est
intéressant que vous parliez de l'exil
parce que c'est aussi l'histoire d'une
famille qui se décompose et ça c'est
très très important parce qu'il y a je
connais pratiquement aucune famille en
Iran qui n'a pas été marquée par par
cette question là du déchirement et de
l'exil c'est ce que vous vouliez montrer
aussi oui la rupture malheureusement
fait partie de notre histoire je le
traite je la traite dans tous mes films
en fait ça revient sous différentes
formes et c'est pour ça que je pense à
ça et que je le montre parce que je suis
la deuxième génération mais il y a
encore une générale ma fille aînée à
Paris mon grand-père venait de
l'Afghanistan mon père a grandi en Iran
moi j'ai vécu ici ma fille est née en
France enfin voilà ça vous raconte tout
et vous avez choisi un jeune garçon ce
qui a pu m'étonner parce que la
révolution emporter par en tout cas dans
les vidéos qui nous qui nous parviennent
par par les femmes aujourd'hui en Iran
c'est un choix pour dire aussi attention
ça n'est pas que les femmes qui se
soulèvent en Iran aujourd'hui vous
vouliez que ce soit un jeune homme et
bien pendant la guerre c'est quand même
les garçons qui étaient restés fidèles
mais oui à cette question de virilité
vous savez c'était obligation d'être
viril d'être un homme d'être courageux
donc c'était quand même plus juste le
traité par un personnage masculin mais à
côté il y a pas Ali pas lui qui veut
dire la sirène d'ailleurs qui donne le
double titre au film et qui qui enlève
son foulard qui est vraiment au côté de
omide pour résister le double titre au
film La Sirène alors expliquez-nous
c'est l'alerte et en même temps la
figure mythologique en personne veut
dire la sirène ou d'où le titre alors
vous montrer aussi un héron très
cosmopolite où toutes les communautés
religieuses se mélangent les Arméniens
les Juifs
c'est dans ce dans cette ville cette
grande ville donc davadan c'est fini ces
tirant là aujourd'hui non non justement
je tenais allemand alors il y a beaucoup
de gens qui sont partis c'est vrai que
la communauté arménienne abandonne
beaucoup plus petite aujourd'hui que
beaucoup de d'autres minorités ont
quitté l'Iran mais elle elle est comment
dire les Cosmopolis elle est
multiethniques l'Iran d'ailleurs on le
il y a quand même les Juifs les
Arméniens les Kurdes voilà les baluches
plusieurs ethnies qui vivent côte à côte
et je voulais montrer un Iran une
mosaïque loin de ce cliché noir et blanc
qu'on a d'ici qui grâce ou
malheureusement hélas à cause de de la
propagande du régime l'Iran n'est pas ça
Niro n'est pas ça et c'est ça que l'on
tenait à montrer aussi avec Jared
Gervais à qui je rend hommage qui est
l'auteur du scénario du film et la
musique et la musique le fil rouge de
cette histoire il y a une chanson rafam
qui est chantée par la diva iranienne et
La Haye c'est important elle a une place
particulière à nous absolument moi j'ai
un souvenir très voilà très jeune à
l'âge de deux ans j'ai été emmené à
obodden par mon père et je me souviens
d'une diva qui chantait dans un cabaret
noir moi je voilà ça c'est à m'est resté
elle s'appelait pas et le elle
s'appelait tout ça mais elle aurait est
une autre chanteuse qui a dû arrêter de
chanter à la Révolution et c'est un
hommage c'est ce personnage à toutes les
femmes toutes les chanteuses iraniennes
qui ont dû
abandonner ce droit de chanter en public
et comme elle aurait rafting est une
magnifique chanson qu'elle a voilà vous
avez des retours de votre film qui
aurait pu être vu ici ou là sous le
manteau en Iran ou
sous le manteau non mais par beaucoup
d'Iraniens de la diaspora et j'ai
beaucoup de gens tous les gens qui ont
un lien avec ordonne ou viennent me
prendre dans leur faut dire pour pleurer
et dire j'ai retrouvé ma ville ça m'est
arrivé plusieurs fois ces jours-ci ou
des gens originaires dehors puisqu'il y
en a beaucoup en exil quand même
d'exilés sont venus me dire oui j'ai
retrouvé un bout de ma ville à bout de
mon enfance un bout de ce terrain de
foot ce des gens qui m'ont raconté
qu'ils avaient vécu la même chose et
c'est très très touchant on ira le
courage des jeunes et même de toute la
population et est immense il a même
cédait la place à la peur et pourtant on
en parle moins qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire il y a des Iraniens qui peuvent
aussi s'agacer parfois de ces
mobilisations de solidarité ou des
actrices on peut se couper une mèche de
cheveux est-ce que c'est important
malgré tout d'être là même si voilà
c'est c'est une goutte d'eau c'est
important c'est important d'en parler
c'est important de relayer d'être la
voix d'être le relais de cette
résistance alors après parfois il y a
des actes qui peuvent paraître
superficiels agacées j'en conviens mais
malgré tout ce qui est important c'est
aux artistes aux populations l'opinion
publique mondiale je dis et françaises
évidemment d'abord que c'est important
d'en parler de ne pas oublier les
Iraniens et aux politiques je redis la
même chose je dis que c'est vraiment
faire un marché un marché de dupe avec
le diable il faut pas arrêter il faut
arrêter de de les voir
évidemment quand on a un otage dans ce
pays on fait tout pour libérer le tâches
ça je comprends mais il y aura un autre
otage trois semaines après qui sera
voilà captivé par Total
à rien en fait il faut passer outre ce
régime c'est ça la seule solution la
sirène étant sale depuis mercredi
dernier c'est un film de s'épider farci
apprécié par LCP vous restez avec moi
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur parti pris ils vont
vous faire agir ou les accueille tout de
suite allez c'est à vous
Mariette Darrigrand et son désormais
célèbres mots de la semaine haute
tempéré et Nathan de verre
installez-vous qui va revenir sur ces
cette course à la Maison Blanche avec un
candidat dont on parle un peu un peu
moins mais on commence par le bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco bonsoir
Myriam ce soir je vous raconte
l'histoire d'un scénario cauchemardesque
suffocant une France à 50 degrés alors
grosso modo bah c'est à peu près la
température d'un hammam sauf que dans un
hammam on irait généralement entre 10 et
30 minutes donc je vous laisse imaginer
la sensation et aujourd'hui et ben
c'était jour de coloc à l'Assemblée sur
ce sujet coloc organisé à l'initiative
des députés écologistes on écoute Julien
Bayou
Julien Bayou une France à 50 degrés
c'est pas un peu exagéré quand même non
malheureusement il faut s'y préparer en
fait on a pris un retard incroyable dans
la lutte contre le dérèglement
climatique aujourd'hui le dargument
climatique est là il s'emballe on le
mesure on le on le subit et désormais il
faut s'adapter
s'adapter alors qu'on n'est pas prêt en
tout cas c'est ce que dit le 5e rapport
du Haut Conseil pour le climat rapport
publié cette semaine et qui agit comme
une piqûre de rappel le bilan de l'année
2022 est très alarmant une température
record plus 2,9 degrés par rapport à la
période 1930 déficit de précipitation
75000 hectares de forêt brûlés plus de
2800 morts dû au vague de chaleur autre
inquiétude le réchauffement en France
est plus fort que la moyenne planétaire
d'où cette question posée par les
écologistes comment adapter nos modes de
vie au réchauffement climatique
parler d'adaptation ce n'est pas dire
que le réchauffement climatique n'est
pas grave c'est dire c'est déjà une
réalité justement nous devons empêcher
qu'il empire parce que ce qu'on sait
aussi c'est qu'un jour on ne pourra plus
s'adapter quand il n'y a plus d'eau on
ne peut plus s'adapter
alors qu'est-ce qu'il propose les
députés écolos quelles solutions face à
la France en surchauffe et bien les
écologistes sont en train de finaliser
20 propositions elles seront présentées
mardi prochain officiellement parmi ces
propositions adaptées les horaires
scolaires par exemple en fonction des
fortes chaleurs lancées aussi un plan
d'adaptation du bâti en repeignant par
exemple les toits des logements en blanc
ça se fait déjà regardez ça permet en
fait de réfléchir jusqu'à 90% des rayons
du soleil et donc d'abaisser les
températures chez vous autre exemple des
bitumés les cours d'école pour en faire
des cours oasis vous les voyez c'est à
dire avec des surfaces végétalisées en
tout cas les députés écologistes
réclament un plan d'urgence au
gouvernement
vous pointez les mesurettes du
gouvernement et pourtant on a
l'impression quand même que le
gouvernement essaye de faire des choses
par exemple le fond vert pour financer
des projets verts dans les collectivités
ou la politique même de rénovation
thermique des logements c'est pas
suffisant tout ça non le gouvernement
aujourd'hui est plutôt dans
l'impréparation il est en train de
concerter au lieu autour d'une
trajectoire il annoncera un plan
d'adaptation à l'automne j'ai envie de
dire après l'été c'est quand même un peu
ballot je vois qu'en matière de travail
par exemple il n'y a pas vraiment de
réflexion qui est lancé autour de
l'adaptation du travail est-ce qu'il
faut par exemple une température
maximale de travail à partir de laquelle
on aurait un droit de retrait ou une
ouverture de négociation pour adapter
les horaires de travail on n'est pas du
tout à la hauteur de l'enjeu voilà
carton rouge des écologistes pour le
gouvernement le Haut Conseil pour le
climat lui est un peu plus nuancé
l'organisme indépendant reconnaît que
l'action politique progresse même si ça
reste largement insuffisant je cite on
peut dire qu'on a dépassé la politique
des petits pas mais on n'est pas encore
au pas de course merci beaucoup Marco
Abadan j'imagine c'est déjà les 50
degrés plus plus on y est on y est oui
depuis longtemps moi mon prochain film
en fait s'appelle plus 50 degrés ah oui
oui c'est un western un western donc il
y a un décalage par rapport à la réalité
mais en effet maintenant au sud de
l'Iran il fait régulièrement plus de 5
ans
vous vous intéressez à la campagne
américaine gros plan ce soir sur un sur
un candidat particulier oui alors je
vais vous parler d'un homme donc pour
l'introduire déjà chacun peut deviner de
qu'il s'agit un petit panel de citations
de cet homme il a dit qu'il était un
candidat anti-système il a découvert que
la pollution chimique des eaux rendaient
les enfants transgenres il fallait
arrêter de soutenir l'Ukraine car la
guerre en Ukraine préparée par les
États-Unis avait pour but de détruire la
Russie et que les États-Unis en étaient
responsable ou encore c'est la meilleure
que les radiations du wifi entrent dans
notre rentre dans notre cerveau en
ouvrant la barrière hémato encéphalique
alors si je vous demandais qui est cet
individu vous allez Donald Trump ou un
épigone et alors non si je vous disais
quel est son parti vous me diriez sans
doute probablement républicain ou
quelque chose comme ça non plus ah alors
c'est qui alors c'est Robert Francis
Kennedy junior le neveu du président JFK
qui se présente c'est incroyable
primaire du Parti démocrate de la
présidentielle pour défier Joe Biden
alors quelques mots sur lui c'est un
ancien avocat enfin c'est un avocat
spécialisé dans l'environnement
initialement qui a eu une carrière de
progressiste disons qui parlait beaucoup
d'écologie des droits humains etc qui
progressaient
il a eu de plus en plus de déclarations
d'abord complotistes et puis et puis
ensuite xénophobe transfobe etc ce qui
lui a valu d'avoir beaucoup de vidéos
supprimées par les réseaux sociaux
d'avoir beaucoup de félicitations des
partisans de Donald Trump comme Steve
Bannon Tuker Carson etc et le plus
incroyable dans cette affaire c'est que
se présentant aux primaire démocrate
alors on sait pas qui serait les
électeurs est-ce que c'est des vrais
démocrates ou non mais des récents
sondages lui donnent 20% des voix
énormes ce qui est énorme donc on verra
ce qui deviendra de sa campagne mais je
pense qu'on peut en tirer deux leçons
premièrement c'est que les conditions
d'apparition du trumpisme sont toujours
présentes aux États-Unis peut-être
encore plus d'ailleurs qu'en 2015-2016
et deuxièmement c'est une simple
hypothèse mais peut-être que le
trumpisme désigne un phénomène politique
un mouvement de fond qui dépasse en fait
largement et Donald Trump et le parti
des républicains et peut-être même le
clivage droite gauche la contagion du
trampisme à tous les camps mais c'est
vrai que ce sont en fait les des idées
peut-être que les idées ils les avaient
déjà et en fait après ça refait surface
puisque c'est quand même étonnant qu'un
homme puisse changer de bord autant en
restant toujours dans la partie
démocrate et les a libérés en fait c'est
hallucinant à suivre merci beaucoup
Nathan j'ai appris beaucoup de choses on
termine avec obtempérer c'est votre mot
forcément Mariette c'est à vous oui
alors là Myriam on est avec ce mot
typiquement dans la langue
administrative c'est-à-dire une langue
qui complexifix ce qui est simple
obtempérer ça veut juste dire obéir
obéir à un ordre quand un policier vous
demande vos papiers lors d'un contrôle
routier ben voilà vous obtenez vous
obéissez alors pourquoi on prend ce mot
là en particulier pour parler des refus
d'obtempérer après évidemment ce qui
s'est passé avec la mort de Naël alors
d'une façon générale on complexifie la
langue administrative pour montrer la
loi la loi au sens de l'institution et
de la loi 1er degré c'est à dire celle
qui classe en grec c'est une note qui
donnera nomenclature donc il s'agit de
classer des comportements déviants si on
veut et puis en l'occurrence donc c'est
du code pour vivre ensemble en
l'occurrence du code de la route puisque
là on est devant un article L
233-1 du code de la route en fait avec
cette cette obligation à obtempérer donc
je crois qu'on risque 7000 euros
d'amende et puis un an de prison alors
c'est pas rien mais en fait c'est quand
même assez modeste on est disons dans
l'organisation normale de la vie
ensemble donc c'est en fait la loi en
temps de paix sociale exactement on est
en vitesse de croisière on peut social
alors évidemment ce que la cernelle
révèle ou redit parce que ça arrive
régulièrement quand même c'est que
justement cette paix sociale n'existe
pas dans certains endroits de notre
société alors dans ce cas là c'est la
loi qui est touchée mais la loi sens
très profond c'est à dire le Logos le
mot loi vient du Logos et le Logos c'est
une parole qui dit clairement la
frontière entre le bien et le mal le
permis et l'interdit c'est ce cette loi
là qui est touchée en ce moment c'est ce
qu'on a dans le Décalogue c'est ça c'est
à dire les 10 le gosse le gars les 10
assertions importantes que la société
laïque démocratique appris à la Société
biblique tu ne tueras point ça fait
partie de cette loi là alors c'est là où
obtempérer revient parce que il
appartient à cette loi profonde au
départ il faut entendre obtempérer
tempérer c'est ça veut dire tempérer son
corps son comportement Hobbes devant
tout le monde donc c'est la loi humaine
la loi profonde qui est là alors
évidemment il y a un retournement
complet de la situation avec ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui obtempérer et passer
de cette loi profonde à la loi
administrative de surface donc la
question qu'il faut se poser on le voit
bien avec les événements actuels dans
notre pays le mot a complètement
retourné son sens et on a quand même
l'impression qu'actuellement normalement
cette haute tempérance là elle s'adresse
aux citoyens lambda quel que soit son
âge comme à celui qui représente la loi
la police ou le ou l'état donc tout le
monde mais là aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que personne justement
d'accepte d'obtempérer au sens de cet
homme tempérance là collective merci
j'ai rencontrer des choses ça vous
inspire quelque chose un commentaire
l'obtempérance comme comme vertu au-delà
de l'administration
et le détournement de sens merci
beaucoup Mariette pour cette itinéraires
d'amour comme ça que semaine le vendredi
Merci à VOUS s'arrête là et on va voir
la sirène qui est en salle bon démarrage
vous êtes content on a des retours
donc on est encore en train de faire les
présentations
des bas et les retours sont très très
positifs donc j'espère que il fera un
long voyage ce lundi qui s'appelle la
sirène merci beaucoup c'est pitté merci
à vous merci les affranchis Marco
pommier très bon week-end profitez bien
et à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]